this April experience all the fun
excitement and drama of football's
greatest event immerse yourself with our
10 brand-new exclusive modes as you play
in authentic brazilian stadiums and
witnessed the support of newly rendered
crowds that replicate the passion and
pageantry of the FIFA World Cup I'm Matt
proudly producer and EA Sports 2014 fifa
world cup brazil and i'm going to take
you through how we brought to life the
world's greatest tournament with a
deepest set of game modes ever first up
we have rode to the World Cup which
allows players to take control of any of
the 203 FIFA sanction national teams in
what is the most immersive tournament
mode in EA sports history guide your
country through the qualifying rounds
and on to glory in the world cup in
brazil captain your country marks the
return of one of the most popular FIFA
game modes of all time start at the
bottom and work your way through the
squad list to eventually lead your
country through qualifying and on to
lift the trophy at the fifa world cup
final new users will find the mode more
accessible than ever thanks to a brand
new auto positioning system road to Rio
de Janeiro is a new online mode where
players progress across a map of
Brazil's 12 host cities or featuring
authentic licensed stadiums prove your
worth by reaching the final at a steady
old American are the online fifa world
cup you'll need to get out of the group
stage then win four games in a row to be
crowned world cup champion
story qualifying takes you back to the
qualifying process with over 60 real
life scenarios that the world witnessed
the scenarios from all over the globe
story of qualifying allows you to
recreate history with a series of
objectives to challenge you story finals
will be activated at the beginning of
the tournament and updated throughout
you'll be able to play through
challenges based on the narrative of the
day's events keeping you up to date as
stories unfold as ever fifa world cup
will be packed full of additional game
modes will also have kickoff skill games
online friendlies any a sports football
club the 2014 fifa world cup brazil will
be the biggest sporting event of the
year and will bring you closer than ever
before